hello welcome back to getting over it
I don't know why I'm doing this I don't
know why any part of this is happening
but it is happening so I'm getting over
it again
and um
I've been getting better at it I've been
getting better at it I have been getting
better I've been improving slowly and
steadily
and my enemy here the Orange is here to
uh do this it's fine guys you guys are
panicking over nothing it's fine
um yeah we're back at it again with
getting over it which is good a good
thing if you think about it it's
actually a good thing
um so I'm gonna start this off with an
oath as we did last time everyone who is
here I want you to raise both of your
hands
and swear an oath
I solemnly swear you gotta say this out
louder it doesn't work you can't just
type it it has to be said out loud hold
up your hands we're all gonna become a
oath siblings together yes I solemnly
swear that I will not allow my rage to
consume me
that though I may crush my enemies and
Conquer that which I have set out to
conquer and destroy that which I have
set out to destroy I shall not let my
animalistic nature take over my better
sense of self
This I Swear and may my oath siblings
hold me accountable for the rage that
shall burn through me like an inferno
from the deepest depths of hell
so by swear all right we've all oathed
we've also off to a bed off to a bad
start so I got back here basically when
I before because I didn't want to get
there goes the orange sorry everybody
orange is gone I'm not even going to
acknowledge his presence
um but I got back here I probably should
warm up first but I didn't
hole no
nice so I didn't warm up first but
that's okay who needs to warm up when
you're
don't bounce oh
goodness gracious this really does want
to get me
oh boy I'm dead oh
oh
it's fine it's fine you know this is
what it's all about
it's it's about being perseverant it's
about persevering in the face of uh I
the problem was I didn't warm up like I
didn't have my even now like I'm not
clearly not warmed up and my my ability
to control what I'm doing is lacking
hmm
but as I warm up I will get better it's
fine everybody you're panicking over
nothing this is what we swore Upon Our
oath Brethren oh God here we go
interesting oh
that was new
it's fine because
man I'm really testing this am I oh God
careful about that
man if only I could actually uh do that
the shortcut path because if oh no
that's Doom
oh
hi everybody thanks for joining this
dream
for joining the Stream So Glad of you to
stop by here at Old Markiplier HQ good
to know
um that we're gonna be having a good old
time together I am questing to beat this
today again which would be my second
time beating it and uh this again is my
hubris is that even the right word I
don't even know anymore my hubris
for uh daring to whoa
daring to uh
be so bold with my thoughts and um
yeah what
but uh so glad you're here today
playing this game and aptly punishing
myself because today
promoting
the new mystery box from
cloakbrand.com Link in the description
want to get some of the best
stuff from this year at a reasonable
price has collectbrand.com
Link in the description so
this game makes you so mad this game
makes me so relaxed so so incredibly
relaxed because it's just a if you think
about it well if you don't think about
it actually if you think about it a lot
less than you should think about it it's
just a very
very nice game
to play with the whole family
oh I don't know I don't know I don't
know
what
I don't know
it's working though
somehow it's working
as a game this game will give me more
carpal tunnel than any other game in the
history of forever
yeah
have I ever seen speed runs for this
game yes I have and they are ridiculous
and I will get there someday this is my
quest this is the only thing I care
about in life besides the uh ladies
mode in Resident Evil which
I may or may not have gotten do just you
know you'll have to wait for the episode
to be there
uh yeah oh my God
please please
oh man I don't know what it is about
this one segment I can either go through
it really fast sometimes like that and I
do great or it takes me forever
huh but I am getting better at the game
oh oh God
I really wish I could do the shortcut
here wow what the hell
I really wish
I could do the shortcut here
man I just don't know how because it's
like it's something to do with the the
rebounding but I just never get enough
swing I don't know how people generate
sometimes I'll generate like enough
swing to do that in other circumstances
but I just don't know how to do it there
so I can't do that here
because that's not what it's all about
Contour
whole slidey
do you think some of the water that
goose is out if that is what well
if that is water oh
I'm so lucky there I am so unwell
I'm gonna just hold on a second
here because this is this is going a
little funny
oh it's like pushing more than it should
be pushing oh no no no no oh oh oh oh oh
oh God
oh what is with this bushing
what is with the pushing yeah
oh
there we go there we go
future speedrunner coming up right here
oh my God okay if I can get over this
part watch this skill no no yes the
skill that's what you call the recovery
if there's one thing I've Gotten Good at
this game at it's flailing and calling
it a recovery which it is so at this
point it's not random chance anymore it
is purely a strategy and it's a strategy
that works you you
whoa whoa whoa whoa see the pushing the
pushing don't like the pushing
sometimes I like to push no don't like
to put
wow
everybody hold on everybody hold on a
minute everybody hold on a minute
everybody just hold on hold on a minute
we can't do things like that we made an
oath not to let the madness inside of us
out in that way what in the hell was
that
what in the hell is that
what in the hell is that
I have no idea
again weirdness is occurring
I don't know what's going on oh my God
it's like all the control that I had
that I thought I had I no longer have
for some reason I don't know why
oh boy
oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh what is going on
what is going on
what is happening my feet are
uncomfortable where's my other
how are you over there
it's fine don't worry about it it's all
good
I'm fine
oh
okay come on push push pull pull pull
pull pull pull
Push Pull Push Pull
there we go there we go
ah man you know for a few shiny moments
it almost looks like I know what I'm
doing
but uh then the we all know that oh God
oh God all right I'm back where the
stream started great I'm so happy about
this welcome everybody thanks so much
for being here
uh glad you could join me in this moment
this stream is brought to you by the
cloak Ram Mystery Box Link in the
description if you want the exceptional
value
hello available in the link in the
description is a cloak Mystery Box yeah
value in a mystery box and also there's
a super secret
only some of you will be we'll get there
as a spell
the storm is coming here we go here we
go
oh no oh my no
oh my God
I'm just gonna try this real slow and
smooth
because it didn't seem to want to do it
before
I'm pretty sure I can do oh God no no no
no
no
oh
oh my God oh my God oh my God
oh all right
cauldron guy for smash when you know I
don't really play Smash but would not
would not be the worst character I don't
think holy crap I know there's a way
it's like I can't go all the way up I
gotta look for when the hammer kind of
buries into the Rock there we go that's
a better grip
there we go
perfect we're doing great
doing great doing great doing great
doing great someday you know I'll be
Speed Run confident there I'm Speed Run
confident on the previous ones who is
shouting fall I see you Jimmy I see you
Jimmy what are you doing you have no
idea
the length side would go
conquer this
okay this is where things have gone awry
for me before
not here specifically but oh boy it's
the flinging that's not the best
I just gotta avoid flinging because
somehow I think I smacked underneath
that thing up there
and that caused me to
push myself off and back so I just gotta
not do that
oh
oh my God
okay I've turned on the volume
I don't think that's nearly as loud as
it used to be that used to be much much
louder
all right don't worry everybody don't
worry
okay let's take a breather here oh man
I'm only like five minutes into this 10
minutes into this and I I'm here look
you guys can say fall all you want I am
uh believe it or not I'm good at this
I'm good and I'm calm and collected
the oath is very real the oath is
incredibly real if you weren't here for
the oath then you are just against no no
oh my God
oh
foreign
oh my God
there we go
oh yes oh yes oh yes oh yes this is what
I've been referring to most of my life
oh God
no why is the music playing I'm not
failing you're failing oh it's it's
bouncing on the wooden part of the top
there that definitely causes some bouncy
issues
oh
God
all right we are making it we're making
it everyone
we're making it
oh my God yep oh God
oh this bird's kind of tricky isn't it
not for a speed run it well
not for speedrunners of course but for
me who is not a speedrunner definitely
some kind of tricky
come on
I know there's a way
yep yes yes
nope yes
so this is not a fault of the death I
don't think right
is this a fault of the death or is this
not a fall to the death fall fall do it
for Content look I don't do things just
for Content this is the content me
succeeding there is content and success
and I have a great deal of it because
I'm a very success
oh it's fine
I was pretty sure that there was no fall
back there
oh no
oh God
brand Mystery Box Link in the
description the more successful I am the
more the oh yeah
why yeah all right
okay so there's no real failure State
here for some reason I keep
pushing again that's just because I
don't have good control of the hammer
nope interesting
okay
here we go
okay sometimes I get a lot of power
sometimes I don't what is the
determinant in getting a lot of power
versus not a lot of power
maybe it's like bouncing there's
something about the elasticity of all
this I don't know need more of an angle
really is that does that actually give
you more power or something
uh close
oh
yeah I never really know I've never done
it well
oh come on
I think I got stuck here before a long
time just because I can't even before I
couldn't generate a nearly enough uh
actual power okay all right this is sad
okay
yes no come on yes yes yes no no no
whoop whoop
s
it's fine it's fine it's fine everybody
you know why
because I'm getting right on the edge
how do I do that
oh come on why is this more frustrating
than anything of the failure I had I had
the same problem before didn't I God
just get there just get there oh my God
is it like a sensitivity thing is it
because my sensitivity is kind of low
right now
and will I get more power if I whoa easy
there bucko
no
whoa hold on hold on
hold on everybody
I'm turning that [ __ ] down again
because that that ain't that ain't that
ain't gonna fly with me that's too
that's gonna lead to some problems if I
let
that go on but I'm up
I'm up
this is the one
this is the one this is the one this is
the one
oh my God oh my goodness oh my damn oh
yeah that's what I'm talking about
[Music]
okay I know it's over there
I know it's over there why are you
playing music I'm I'm making progress
I'm I'm not failing
oh
oh God nope
[Music]
oh my God I'm starting to lose it guys
oh I'm starting to lose it oh I'm
starting to lose it oh God
I feel the same itch I feel every time I
play a rage game where I do not like the
controls of which there were too many
bad clones of this game before and after
or after only really
why why why
oh come on
why was this so easy the first time and
now it's impossible what now it's in
what now it's in what what now now it's
what
huh what now it's
impossible for me
oh my God are you kidding me oh
my God
fine
I'm a much more calm the oath the oath
my rage shall not consume me the rage
burning inside my soul shall not consume
me
I am the calm
once you're calm that's the thing about
this game that's the thing about this
game not many people realize this but
that's the thing about this game
is that when you let the calm go
and you hold on to the rage
you have nothing left inside of you
except rage and that rage bubbles up and
out and over and keeps you from being
the person you need to be
which is me
no come on now
foreign
brought to you by cloakbrand.com
new mystery box sold today get an
exceptional value
incredible value I gotta see it to
believe it the value
the value is astonishing in every way
how am I gripping that
what how is that gripping that that's
incredible
that was incredible how was that
how is that gripping that
that was astonishing
I don't even know it could grip that
much
anyway
hey
now that's what I call
control
oh no no no no why are you going on no
no no no don't don't know me I'm fine
yes yes
perfect
yes
oh
easy there buckle
all right
oh
okay good news everybody we're doing
great oh ride the snake now see this is
what
tells me
I think you guys don't actually care
about me
or who I am as a person how could you
possibly want me to break my oath
and ride that snake oh good God oh
I don't cry almost wrote it I almost
rode the snake oh my god oh calm down
calm down calm down everybody calm down
everybody calm down
everybody just calm everybody calm
everybody be calm calm down calm down
everybody calm down everybody calm down
everybody calm down oh
I just booped it snoot that's all I did
I just bopped the little snake on the
nose
it's nothing whoa interesting all right
the boat the bucket rejected me
which is fair I guess
it's inferior to my cauldron anyway
okay here we go
that's very gentle in there
God not like that not like that oh
interesting everybody calm down
everybody calm down why do I do this to
myself look I'm succeeding I'm
succeeding I don't know what you guys
are talking about I'm succeeding right
now I am succeeding I'm doing great this
is fantastic everything is good
everything's good everything is
fantastic in life
and with me so I'm not no don't panic
okay just got a swing swong a little bit
swing swung
yup oh
let me just rest here a moment I don't
even know if I can get up over on the
left there
is there an invisible wall there
could I make I think I can make this
jump
can't you make this jump
can you make this jump
I don't remember I think you can
I think you can make the job
no no yes no I'm getting a lot of mixed
signals here there's a lot of mixed
signals going on I think you can
yep yes you can absolutely oh easy there
oh
oh guys
[Laughter]
this is the final climb
this is the final climb everybody this
is the final climb
It's the final climb if I
can just
like oh okay oh
oh I know there's little there's little
divots in it there's there's little you
gotta hit it hard you gotta but if I hit
it hard it might oh my push my push my
push might push no no don't push don't
push don't now now
everybody calm down
everybody calm down
is it you go slow is it go slow
lady dimitrisk who's down the snake I
don't believe you
I don't believe you we all made Oaths
we're Oaths siblings look to your left
look to your right those are your oath
siblings I know there's like little
divots that's a divot that's a divot in
there
and you can
I don't know if you can re you can't
rest your bucket on it can you oh you
can
oh you can you can rest your bucket in
the tits okay this is perfect
oh
oh incredible incredible incredible
outstanding outstanding outstanding
oh
I'm gonna go faster you out of your mind
oh God I'm too Twitchy I'm too Twitchy
for this I'm too twitching for this
everybody this stream is brought to you
by cloak brand uh there's a link in the
description to a lovely Mystery Box go
check it out I need to come
oh
oh okay
oh
ah
okay
oh thank you
thank you Laura like thank you much
all right
here we go
cloak brand is done the snake
oh I'm not in a divot okay where's it
stop
oh I can't do this oh no oh no oh god oh
I'm gonna screw I'm gonna choke I'm a
choke I'm a joke I know they made a new
clothing game oh I'm gonna choke
[Laughter]
give me the old Rizzle nizzle I'm trying
I'm trying
oh you just gotta be calm gotta be
gotta be calm gotta be cool collected a
weird way too Twitchy at the moment
approaching for docking
perfect of it
docking
[Music]
God I know if you slide off at this
point it's almost guaranteed you go down
the snake it's like for some reason
I know I want to go fast that's what I
think the right way is that's what I
think the right way is but I like I know
if I go slow it's just gonna go bad for
me I know that's how it works and if I
go fast it's gonna go portal I need to
go fast but calm is what I have to do
I'm not look I don't I I don't want to
go down the snake if I slip on this and
I go wrong it puts you right down the
snake
I know it's like fast and accurate I got
this
okay
it's your first stream here in months
I'm Not Gonna Let You Down
here we go
calm and collected
what
what
oh
I'm Not Gonna Let You Down never get
Never Gonna Let You Down
oh
let's just calm down
oh my God
oh take it slow but fast but calm but
energetic I'm trying man
I don't man I know I got it I got it I
got it calm collected calm smooth this
is what it's all about
this this is where
I Define myself my journey has been
arduous
at this point I haven't been sure that
I've been capable of doing what it needs
to be done
but I will persevere why do I keep going
up angle why does it keep angling up I
don't want to go angle up I know it can
hold me at that angle I don't need to
rotate is the thing I don't need to
rotate I just need to pull don't rotate
pull don't rotate oh
I had the strategy I had the strategy
the strategy was there it's you you if
you rotate out see if you pull from here
you're fine as soon as you go up and out
you lose traction that's the thing
that's the seek if you go up like that
but it really wants to go up like that
however you can fight that urge
and you can pull straight in
and that's
oh my God oh my God
okay you know what screw it I'm just
gonna go for it
yes yes yes no yes yes no yes
what
stop
I'm getting worse I'm getting worse I'm
getting so much worse I'm getting I'm
somehow getting worse ha
whoop
hmm I'm getting worse how am I getting
worse how how am I getting worse I was
better I was so I like my first I got
here and I'm getting worse I'm getting
worse I'm panicking I need to stop but
I'm not stopping oh my God I need to
stop I need to pause I need to calm down
oh my God I need to calm down oh stop
stop swinging God I'm going for it yeah
I need to calm down
just ordering a mystery box better be
worth it oh trust me it'll be so worth
it
it'll be so worth it
I'm stressing you out all right I can't
help that you know I can't help that I'm
just it's just stressful it's stressful
don't concentrate on the results just
concentrate on the process you're right
you're right you're right
the process which is sponsored by cloak
brand
dot com Link in description
the mystery box
you must know
what's in the mystery box
huh
oh
right there
right there
oh
no no no no no no no no
I won't allow it okay this is the second
stage
of this climb and now it gets more
dangerous than everything because if I
slip here I do slide too far I think
here is the delineation
here's the delineation
here's the delineation this is the
delineation okay
oh man
oh come on
nope
foreign
foreign
I'm trying to pull in I'm not trying to
scoop it just really wants to scoop
he just really wants to scoop it's okay
no don't go up whoa when you were right
there
go it's um
it just keeps wanting to go up it keeps
wanting to go up and I'm like don't go
up why don't you not go up why don't you
just focus on the pole like that
which is what I'm trying to do nobody
goes up it bounces up
oh oh
you were there you were there you were
there oh you were there you bastard no
oh
it was oh
it was right there oh he's right there
come on just pull
next pull
relax if it catches it catches pull
Paul
who don't go up every time go up it
detaches
well that's no no no
hole no
oh stop going up Dean God no go come on
no God no
oh
oh don't push out where I go up oh don't
do that thing I'm trying everything not
to do oh thank you oh wow here I was
pushing when I was like oh why am I not
working oh I don't do the thing I've
literally been screaming about to not do
for the past 30 minutes oh thank you
thank you so much
foreign
using the hammer to move
I have not
I think maybe
I'll try that strategy sounds like it
might work ah you're right
it turns out that the hammer was the key
to everything
that is astonishing here I was
not using the hammer and it turns out
that when you use the hammer
wow
that is really some thing
special stop going up
oh
what come on
no stop going up
the oath is everything everyone the oath
is everything I am the oath I am the
oath we are all the oath
listen when we make an oath like this
we must remember
the oath is everything
if we were to break our oath who would
we be
we would surely not be oath siblings as
we
so desire to be
no
we would be
deserters of the oath
the truth is the oath
we are all
we are all
whoa
you're all one
under the Earth
my
anger does not define me
I am
so much more than
my rage can I
will stop pop out
foreign
oh mother
oh my God
this was not even that hard before this
was not even that hard the last time I
did this
stop pushing away from the mountain oh
really is that what I need to do oh wow
yeah you know the thing is uh funny
about that I never thought of that I
never thought of that I'll just have to
try something else
hmm oh my God I swear I can't I can't
not
my my mouse I don't even move my mouse
after that I like I go up I hit it in oh
that time it didn't do what I was trying
to illustrate
nor that time maybe I am maybe some
subconscious part of me is trying to
like autocorrect
that's working out nicely
I'm just kind of like catching and not
moving
seems to be working
maybe you were right maybe the advice is
just hey don't push away from the
mountain and by golly
what
no no no
no
every time right there oh every time I
[ __ ] it up right there
sure why
oh
I swear I'm not moving it after I I hit
it and then I let go of the mouse and
it's just like it rebounds
not sure why
yeah I didn't I let go of my mouse there
and it bounced up and off that's is it
something is it like me over it might be
me over hitting uh
well here we go
is it like me over uh Landing where I'm
trying to go because there is some
elasticity no it's not that either
yeah I hit it and I go back is it
because I hit it too hard is it because
I I am kind of going too far into the
mountain I I just like even to this day
I don't really know the mechanics of
this
there we go
nope
every time right there
can't seem to get a grip on that no oh
don't bounce up
oh
stop
pull
hmm
what
oh
oh no oh God I had oh come on
oh
sure
I'm not trying I'm not trying to lift up
oh my God
I'm
I'm not trying
oh God I swear
oh
oh
oh oh
my God
oh
all of your advice seems to be all for
nothing because here I stand at the top
of everything I'll send 200 bucks if you
ride the snake no I'm not gonna do that
I stand at the top of everything
a shining Beacon of what is
the most glorious success of my life and
I
will not allow myself
robbed of this Victory oh my God I am
incredible hype
oh yes oh yes
did I mention
this is sponsored by
cloakbrand.com
Link in the description get your mystery
box today oh my God oh my God I actually
I think I did it I know it's not over
yet and I shouldn't be counting my oh I
gotta be careful oh my God
okay okay I know I'm not there yet I
know I'm not there yet but this is what
it means to make an oath
oh this is what it means to make an oath
this is what it means to make an oath
this is what it means to make an oath
this is
what it means to make an oath
[Music]
what
oh
what
what did
what is happening what is what is what
is happening
what's going on
what's going on I swear I'm not goofing
I don't know what's happening this
should be the easiest thing in the world
at this point after what I just did
because I can get that just fine why is
this one slippery and hard to get there
we go
oh this
okay okay okay
all right okay all right okay
what
why is this hard this part is easy
at least that's what I remember
why is this hard this should not be hard
hmm
what happened to me
stop pushing away from the tower
ah you got me there all right okay
enough goofing now let's get this for
this is strange this is this shouldn't
be this way I I don't know let's just
stop goofing it's it's serious time now
I can't stand up there
okay
all right let's serious time here
there we go there we go oh and then I
yep
okay oh okay all right oh my God
I am questioning everything about my
life at this point I'm questioning
absolutely everything
oh
no no no no oh God no no no no no
oh no
oh no
I didn't even ride the snake
I didn't even get to ride the snake how
did that happen I I knew it was gonna
happen because for some room
it's just so pushy you know I I I don't
ha
can is there a guide
is there a guide
is there is there a guy that I can look
at that can be like what's the actual
tips with which to do this because I you
know maybe it's gonna be a video I'm
gonna look it up it's gonna be like
don't push away from the mountain and
that's gonna be it like uh
I I need
I need something
I just need something
I
need
something what do we got
no I don't care about step by step no
no
no
no
I don't need it I don't need this I
don't need anything but my own skill
should I be using what is trackpad
tuning even do that's what I've been
using I don't even know maybe maybe I
shouldn't use that I don't know
something like that track bad tuning
probably bad I don't know not playing on
track bad so who knows maybe that was a
terrible idea is there something
fundamentally different about trackpad
tuning I don't know
is that bad good I don't know if anybody
even knows whoop whoa
interesting
never been here before
track bed tuning is good more accurate
oh man is it I don't know
I just I'll use this one I'll I'll see
for myself what the difference is oh
well oh God oh God you're right it's
probably more accurate holy [ __ ] this is
different
well that's weird well I'm not out of
the woods yet apparently
you know what I'm gonna use trackpad
tuning I don't know what that's about
but
oh man
oh man
uh
that hurt so bad
that hurts so you don't understand I was
oh man now it's too sensitive I don't
know what I'm doing everybody
guys I just don't know what I'm doing
with my life
oh probably the last thing I should do
is change the control scheme mid-run
oh that's probably not the best idea oh
well here I go
oh
it's okay because in reality I already
know what I need to do to get back to
where I was and that's all that matters
so and I have
what is the difference between trackpad
tuning I I would really actually like to
know maybe I should look that up maybe
maybe I should look that up
that'll be what I look up what's uh
what's the difference between
getting over it here we go getting over
it track pad versus mouse
tuning
ah what does actually distracted tuning
do uh in my testing I determined that
it's much easier to make fine very fine
movements with a trackpad Mouse users
we're getting hand cramps from trying to
hold their hand very still so I added
acceleration curve ah
so Mouse has acceleration
it's fine if you prefer nearly all my
testers prefer the mouse tuning I
I don't like Mouse tuning I never have
Mouse acceleration on anything I do
huh
trackpad it is we're going trackpad
that was from Bennett
the man himself the developer
who needs who needs to try who needs
Mouse tuning well here I go again I
guess I was just I wanted to do I wanted
to do it again
I just wanted to do it again you know I
was having so much fun I just decided
that I was going to do it again
that's what this game's all about having
fun well here I go but I wanted to do it
again I wanted to do it all again why
not go back to the beginning it's just
so fun see I know I could be working
towards a golden cauldron with like 50
wins but you know I I find it better
that if I actually don't win and
just do the whole thing over again
multiple times anyway
watch this move
that's what I call Pro move
foreign
all right
oh
it's all good
there's no up
oh God
hmm
oh
there we go
there we go
if your hand cramps up from using the
trackpad tuning your hands ain't strong
enough that's what I always say
that's what I always say all right now
take two I think that this this here is
actually a detriment this this table
being here is oh well you know I almost
thought about doing it again but uh I
decided against it this one time I know
call me crazy
this is a perfect example of why you
need to pull
instead of launching so don't push away
from the mountain especially here
but additionally if you don't have to
there's nothing wrong with taking things
a little oh I'm dead I'm dead I'm alive
God damn I'm good
God damn I'm good
oh my God Appears for pull all right
we're gonna make an oath here whoa okay
interesting that was not whoa okay oh
calm down calm down calm down
calm down
we're gonna make another oath that we're
never ever going to push away from the
mountain that's just what we have to do
okay
oh God oh God oh God oh God
thank you
oh my God oh God no no no oh no God why
is that so hard for me
why do I make every oh
oh I should stop I should stop I should
calm down I'm not coming down I'm in a
frenzy I'm in a frenzy oh my God I made
a frenzy holy [ __ ] I'm in a frenzy God
I'm frenzying
yeah I'm going for it
made it that's how you do that's how I
do anyway oh good here I go I'm in a
frenzy oh I'm in a frenzy
I'm in a frenzy you can't stop me
I'm friendsing I'm friendsing that was
an incredible launch why couldn't I do
that any other time when I'm trying to
do this exploit of how to get through
that section
quicker oh
yeah yes yeah just like this yeah
sorry I got a little sexual there but
it's fine sometimes you need that energy
to get through to where you're gonna go
that's all that matters
it's not about the destinations about
the journey
all right
oh
oh
no that's how you that's how you mess up
I know what I'm doing seems crazy
because before I did this like calmly
and you know without
trying to do too many fancy moves
not that these moves are fancy at all
but just trying to get better at
controlling
as opposed to constantly okay uh
oh there I go oh I had it and I let go
oh come on I had it and I let go
oh oh shut up oh shut up
oh shut up I had it and I let go of it
because I thought I was done oh my God
[Music]
oh my God just go the oh
go okay
I'm tilted everybody I'm tilted I'm
tilted I'm goddamn tilted again God damn
it I was there God I was at the end I
was at the end I was gonna be able to go
God I was I was done Why didn't it do
anything there
[Music]
what is happening oh my God no not like
this what are you doing okay perfect
that's exactly what I meant to do
[Music]
whoa whoa
whoa whoa see that was such a launch
what was that about
come on oh
such a launch why was that such a launch
if I could do a launch like that I'd be
able to get up here the shortcut but I
don't know what I'm doing differently
see like that wasn't a launch but this
somehow that's just so much distance how
am I doing that
oh
is it like I'm just getting better at
pulling am I getting good oh my God guys
I might be getting good nope
guys nope
guys nope yes I might be getting good
guys I might be getting good I might
actually
I might no please I might be getting
good guys I might be getting good
might be I might be getting good
ooh might be getting good guys
what
what
I'm
getting good
I might be getting good guys
like that
okay good
then I just need to oh come on
I know you got it in you
oh stay yes yes
we're back in business no oh why
what
I
was
good
there we go
foreign
there we go
there we go oh
all right I'm starting to get the hang
of just pulling
it's taken a long time to get here but
I'm starting to get the hang of it
starting to get the hang of it
shockingly you would never believe it if
you looked at what happened what just
happened
did it get stuck in there and it like
leveraged out I think that's what
happened that's the only thing my
analytical brain which is incredibly
prodigious was able to discern from that
particular encounter
it got wedged in there it's wedged right
now and when it popped out it pushed me
out
that hasn't that why is that suddenly
happening uh it's because I'm getting so
good guys
it's because I'm actually getting
skilled because I'm getting incredibly
skilled
we're back in it we're back in this
we're back in this we're back in this
we haven't given up not on our Oaths
not on ourselves and not on our oath
siblings we're here we're ready we're
looking for
love in all the wrong places
oh what a pull what a pull
oh
God
okay we're on the road again
on the road please
all right cool
we're on the right Road
I don't even know how that stayed I kind
of swung out again
right this this is where it all comes
together it all comes together right
here the skill
the skill
never mind
the skill
never mind
all right
the skill
let's kill one
there we go
okay I swear I didn't do that
that's what I'm talking about
this is what it's all about
pour back in it we're backing it every I
say that every time every time
every time I say that I'm like we're
back in it and then it's like yeah no no
no you're not no you're not no you're
not
you're not I got it I got
you know why
because I got it
never mind
don't got it
nope pushed away
I don't got it okay now I got it I got
everybody hold on I got it
okay and I did the thing again I pushed
away
oh man
never mind oh I've lost it I've lost it
I've lost it all oh my God everybody
have lost it all
what
no
we're back in it everybody I'm saying it
loud I'm saying proud we're back in it
we're back we're back baby we're back
we're back baby
oh no oh
oh God why is it sometimes such a wimpy
hit it's sometimes so wimpy
it's sometimes so wimpy I don't
understand why but it just is
not oh
come on
oh my God are you kidding me
oh why did it just slide I had it
planted so fine
oh God
oh
[Music]
I had it planted so perfectly and it
didn't why is it so weak sometimes I
don't understand
why is it so weak
what is it like I got a recoil it wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
interesting thing go back like see how
that reticle comes in
Maybe
maybe is that what it is
no no how I don't
oh I don't understand
anything about this game I still after
all these hours of playing it I have no
idea
whoo
use Anvil to super jump I don't
know how do you super jump how is is
that even a thing how do you do it no
one's explained how oh it's just super
no oh my God
oh my God
okay that's just making fun of me that's
just making fun of me
that's just making fun of me why would
it do that then it's just like ah here's
a really big bounce for no movement you
didn't move at all right okay we're
gonna move your cauldron guy real far
nope nope nope nope nope
nope
stop what are you doing
we're back in it baby
oh
imagine a stamina bar in this game I
don't want to imagine that
what
[Music]
what happened
what what just happened what what
just happened I don't even know what
happened what I just slid off it and I
know it's ice but
that doesn't usually happen does it
I don't think so anyway
whatever
okay
what hmm
oh
nope
come on come on come on come on you're
really fighting me
no why
why in the dick happened it's just I
didn't move a freaking muscle and it
just decided I'm gonna loop around again
I didn't move guys I didn't move why did
it just you saw it when haha he got
excited why did he get excited I didn't
move how can he do another full
elliptical rotation without my input
is that possible
he got excited
he was jazzed up
oh
how do you get jazzed up that hard
oh God
okay
okay
so far so good man this song is long
no no no
it's something bad happening
there we go
okay
oh
pause move Mouse is that what it is
interesting
let me try that
nah they must have patched that out
I don't think that's a thing
nah that ain't a thing it might have
been before but
it's got to be something else
I know it's just momentum use your leg
ah use your legs
uh you might have something to that
all right here we is Gang
oh I'm not gonna make that oh okay I'm
back shockingly
whoa
whoa what pull this is where I would
pull
all right
we're back on the mountain
we're back where we were how long ago 30
minutes ago we're we're making good time
oh boy and I I don't think I've got an
air I've gotten a little better
a little better at pulling
a little better
a little better
hmm
oh
oh God
okay I'm back oh God I'm back but now
I'm afraid I'm afraid everybody I'm
afraid oh man I'm afraid oh my God I'm
afraid holy [ __ ] I'm afraid oh my god oh
I'm afraid you could oh man I can't even
get up the steps oh God I just I freak
out oh I can't even make it up here oh
man I'm freaking I'm freaking guys I've
already beat this game before and I'm
still freaking
oh boy
hey how you doing uh as you know about
the cloak brand mystery boxes available
through the link in the description
below incredible value check out that
link in the description below my sanity
is
paying for all of this
oh
wow how did that grip
whoa calm
down
calm down I swear the more you move it
the more sensitive it like there's
there's like a sensitivity curve on this
oh
man
[Music]
I am so struggling I'm so struggling
with the most basic stuff I can't
believe it how have I made it this far
if this is what's going to be there
how is this gonna be it this is gonna be
it
oh there we go
[Music]
okay
oh yeah oh
I had that
oh I had that okay
all of my training
all of my skill building
[Music]
all my screening all my training is for
nothing all my training is bunk all my
training is nothing all my training all
those years wasted wasted wasted wasted
wasted I'm I'm I'm useless I've got no
oh oh my god I've got no skill I'm
freaking I'm freaking I should pause I
should pause I should pause but I'm not
pausing I'm not pausing because I'm good
I'm controlled I'm I'm in it oh God I
gotta I'm not stopping I don't know why
oh my God I can't stop it all right
please somebody ah
and that's all it is here we go that's
all it takes everybody that's what the
training is all about it's not about not
freaking freaks will happen but it's
about getting back to Center quicker
than ever
it's about getting back to Center
quicker than ever yep okay oh about
getting back to Center I'm centered
my spirit and my soul
so even
so nice
what okay
okay
centered soul is centered oh God
soul is centered I'm going partially
blind I haven't blinked in ages
Hi how are you doing
oh
ah oh
that's not good oh man
holy crap this is so stressful for me
and not for you guys this is just pure
entertainment for you I know this
I'm aware of this and I know how we all
work
okay
hmm
interesting interesting
okay
oh man it's just
this shouldn't be this hard because this
is like this is like the exact same as
that that area in the beginning that I'm
able to do sometimes incredibly well
sometimes not incredibly well it's like
basically the same
oh my God
guys
oh boy
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh my god
oh I did it
oh wow
holy crap I did it again
[Laughter]
wow
look at that
is that the same credit sequence as it
was before I don't even remember that
wow
this victory was brought to you by cloak
brand Link in the description if you
want a sweet delectable Mystery Box go
check it out before the boxes run out
Lincoln
the description I'm also back
[Music]
that's beautiful but I'm talking right
now
thank you I'm also back making normal
videos uh once again I basically have
been sprinting with work for a very very
long time and uh it's been quite a
couple months here to get all the work
that I had done like I was pulling like
14 16 hour days for about two and a half
months that's why videos have been
sporadic but
I'm glad to be back I'm glad to be done
it was another great thing where I was
just like I woke up this morning and I
was just like man I don't have a crazy
looming deadline
so
I have all the various projects that I
want to make you know uh that I've been
working on but you know those are now my
pardon them are done thank you guys so
much for watching my mom's documentary
um it meant a lot to me and it meant
even more to my mom if you didn't get a
chance to watch my mom's documentary I'm
sorry it's too late now but uh I
understand things get busy uh the only
fans will be uh started at the end of
this month probably the first of
December
um and no just like thank you so much
for your patience I've been working on
some pretty crazy things I mean space
got nominated for an Emmy which is just
nuts to think about I'm going to the
Emmys on
in December I just
it's just nuts to think about how far
that's come so thank you if you don't
want to know what spaces you know I
guess you could check it out
um
yeah
just thank you
thank you so much for uh
being there for me and I'm going to get
back to making cool
stuff for you
lots of cool stuff I mean that's what
I've been doing is making cool stuff for
you for the while there's just like it's
hard to see sometimes for the higher
production stuff but back to normal
videos and crazy stuff like this and hey
I beat getting over it again
which I didn't think would happen
yeah get the bad ending now isn't the
bad ending just going off to the left I
solemnly swear that I'm not recording
and streaming
oh
who is waiting for me
all right fair enough thank you guys
thank you all right
well anyway let's hit it again
all right ready for round three here I'm
going for the golden bucket
doesn't it just go this way
I don't know if that qualifies as the
bad end but
that does work for me
again I do kind of Wonder like I have
gotten a little better with the
well no I say
with the actual like pulling thing
well nope
somehow I'm even worse than I was before
whoa what happened there
what
ah oh
boy
turns out I'm even worse than I was
before
how am I worse
oh
how am I worse I don't get it
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
all right
all right
I'm doing it
shockingly I'm doing it
I'm still not great at the pulling I'm
still not great
shockingly not great
whoa
[Music]
no there's no way there's no way I could
do this whoop no I'll just go the other
way maybe
[Music]
look at me go
you'll see in this
you'll see in this
you seeing this
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
no
oh oh oh God
[Music]
all right
oh
I'm going for it
[Music]
there's the orange
good God look at me go oh my God
I'm like getting oh [ __ ] there I go nope
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
frick I'm done okay all right well okay
I did my best I did my best I did my
best all right I'm done I'm done I'm
done I'm done I'm not trying that again
God damn it I still can't not push away
from the goddamn mountain
I still can't not push away from the
goddamn mountain it was not the orange
the orange has no power over me there's
not the Orange's fault the oranges
deserve to die it is fine
anyway thank you guys so much for being
a part of this uh hopefully I'll see you
real soon which I will meaning tomorrow
with more sweet delectable content tell
the world Markiplier is back because I
am did you miss me I'm here again get
ready for more cool stuff coming at you
hot and fast thank you so much for being
here and thank you so much for watching
yes I did find Lady
and yes I did complete Resident Evil
I've recorded quite a few things in
there
they're ready for you real soon look
forward to that thank you
I am an Emmy nominated creator
that certainly won't go to my head
thank you everybody so much I can't wait
to get back into normal videos but you
have a lovely day I'm gonna go record
more and then make more beautiful sweet
content for you thank you and as always
I will see you
in the next video
bye-bye oh yeah also Mystery Box
clickbrand Link in description thank you
uh